welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by me undies listen to me it's the
holidays you're gonna get away undies
you're gonna get on these who needs on
these but if they're real underwear like
me on these that's an amazing gift
they're comfortable they that they're
flexible that three times softer than
cotton then natural that sustainably
source fiber listen this is the way to
go so what I'm going to do is the
holiday season is upon us
I'm gonna give you 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you'll ever wear
period free shipping and under percent
money-back guarantee satisfaction
guarantee how's that me on these calms
less Joey
that's me undies comm slash Joey this
shows also brought to you by lift let me
tell you why I like lift number one lift
is the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
they believe that being a ride-sharing
drivers should be fun and if you're
having a good time
so other passengers so again join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to lift
calm slash Joey today right now right
now don't even mess around and get a 500
our new driver bonus $500 that buys a
lot of stuff that's lift calm slammed
Joey again lift docked on slash Joey
limited time only terms apply kick that
[ __ ] me Olli what's the more
with Jeff [ __ ] Spicoli in the
eighties that where American surpassed
times a guy masturbating that I've typed
that [ __ ] video in right now well
yeah that could be considered I guess
yeah right can you believe how much
we've changed what am i oh [ __ ] the
other night me and my wife got snot
watching and that that stuff is it's one
of the greatest films of all time office
in a gentleman yeah all the Richard
Gere's best [ __ ] war yeah yeah in the
first 30 minutes he says 22 [ __ ]
offensive things like just [ __ ]
offensive that you decide
and he beats up a guy breaks his nose
I'm like look how much time ya have
changed that that was just and he says
something he said something offensive
like uh racial racial oh yeah just a
rich okie from Muskogee or something
[ __ ] right there yeah Phoebe this is the
one they've been looking for they like
been hunting her down right here look
how beautiful she was
[Music]
look at this [ __ ] Lee you know how cute
I look at this [ __ ] girl they just up
that it down she looks like me just
hunting it down Yahoo and now the sister
catches a blasted off one watch watch
this or somebody catches him blastin I
think she catches them look at them this
is real comedy people whack it off with
a pirate this is real family right here
this is where your [ __ ] Tommy this is
a classic [ __ ] film look at her
Jesus Christ nobody remembers this [ __ ]
I got a drop knowledge every [ __ ] day
that was a fake [ __ ] alpha Brian I
remember all these deep down secrets I
do love that watching old movies new C
stuff that wouldn't like pass today like
they wouldn't they wouldn't let it in at
all like you had that one that TV show
where the guy said the n-word in the in
the courtroom or something
Oh Sanford Sanford and sons you know he
yeah they haven't on YouTube go to you
Sanford and Son courtroom scene it's
it's it's brilliant and it's it's well
then I was reading that Angela Lansbury
she's like 92 years old and then she
came out and was like you know sometimes
it's woman's fault too and blah
a third one and people got on her but
it's like she's a 92 year old woman she
had to bear the brunt of all of the evil
I don't I mean the NBC I'm black oh
you'd enjoy that don't count this why
don't you arrest some white drivers I do
you do well where are they look at all
these [ __ ] innit
compete
there's enough [ __ ] in here to make
it look at the league see look at this
is 19 what Felicia no this is like 75 or
4 right yeah this is this is this is a
great show
yeah so [ __ ] crazy that I get stuck
sometimes watching movies and you know
when you know like like you look at that
press that Archie Bunker around the Jews
again
CBS 1970 you know this is crazy how much
we've changed yeah you must be doing
pretty good at being a lay out eight ten
dollars a day for clean woman ten
dollars oh they're getting more than
that for good cleaning people today
maybe she's a live-in maid Why What are
you stronger body
the only people nowadays can afford
living help of rich people and Jews not
all Jewish people are rich well never no
one it wasn't
the Steiners from our old neighborhood
weren't they didn't have as much as we
did to hear them tell it hey you don't
suppose Bowman sold his house to one of
that tribe do you I mean he was always a
Jake but he wouldn't do a thing like
that to this thing a rich Jewish person
could afford to hire a maid why would he
buy Jim Bowman's old house to make
trouble you know these people are always
looking to make a test case what do you
think they got that their organization
there what do you call it to burn a bris
I'm just gonna take a walk already
timplemans house and I'm gonna talk to
him about it that's all where's my
lumberjack right in there
well somewhere in there but somewhere in
there ain't right in there
how about right in there somewhere
what's right there you sure have your
little ways at torture my mine the bald
man McNabb yeah used to live down the
street there remember at a time that he
was gonna sell this place to them Jews
all and you come around with that
petition to all the rest of us to sign
remember keep mouth we all signed yeah
yeah you really saved the block that
time Jim well you know me I mean you
wouldn't then turn around and do what
McNabb was trying to do with you you
mean sell to Jews yeah oh these people
are Baptists I just talked with the
telephone company and they are putting
my phone in today now I really believe
the house is mine oh hi neighbor
and that's the birth of the Jefferson we
believe that the nature
that's the burglar just such great TV
right you know it was the cool that's
you never than the Coons are come just
leave a lot of it I mean this is we're
watching all this [ __ ] Texas what this
represents is the struggle of the races
its rudl The Shining hope of a new
brotherhood see
the girl has gone face I'm all alone
isn't anybody else interested in
upholding standards how well just common
crumbling down the Coons are coming this
is CBS Felicia watching 12% of the
population is black they should be aware
like families living out here yeah this
is only a beginning but I think it's
wonderful wonderful huh well let's see
how wonderful it is when a watermelon
rinds come flying out
[Applause]
Wow right oh my god oh my god we all
about these episodes and it's tough
cause like they're funny because like
you see how ridiculous they are now but
there are people were like yeah the Jews
are moving in but nobody was complaining
well because it had a morality to it you
or he would learn his little lesson you
know what I mean it wasn't you know when
Sammy Davis kissed him little lips
yeah that time or when the Puerto Rican
guy found his wallet I remember that it
was an episode what a reading guy found
his wallet and he couldn't [ __ ]
believe the Puerto Rican was returning
it you know was such a son I went the
border region came over either hi Hector
it's the guy that was the typical Puerto
Rican listen he in fact he was the
original cat he was Julio he was Julio
on Sanford & Son
he played every Puerto Rican and he
comes in he goes mr. bunker here's the
wallet I found and the cash is still
your a hero you know I never expected
bump he goes eat it don't you stand
there getting solid drink it early turns
IGAs see us I don't know what to offer
him and you know like the guys right
there he goes
how about some pineapple juice you know
like and even as a kid I didn't get it
didn't offend me in no way at all well I
think it must be interesting like for
Lee to watch it because we remember it
from when we were kids so if you might
make sense in the time television today
I can you imagine that on set listen Sam
from the Sun came on at 8:30 on Fridays
she's not the Chico and the man on 8
okay was Chico in the man and with
Freddie Prinze which was it's a man yeah
I can't explain to you what it meant to
a guy like me on Friday night I didn't
do anything I didn't do anything till 9
o'clock
so she cloned the man and Sam from the
Sun was over with and then they had
crime story with Andrew Dice Clay nobody
[ __ ] remembers that either it was no
I'm lying to you people that was earlier
than Freddie Prinze died then add a the
whole thing went down the tubes and then
they came out with Miami Vice at nine
and crime story with Andrew Dice Clay at
ten
that was a good [ __ ] show no it was a
good show yeah for sure for sure it's on
Friday nights live you were 13 you watch
Sampson son you just didn't you parents
went out on Fridays and you were like
thank God bye yeah we're gonna do
homework [ __ ] you we're gonna get a
pizza from salves I'm gonna sit in one
cheek on the man and laugh and then
we're gonna [ __ ] what I still
understand watch him saying the [ __ ]
thing about don't you arrest any black
people where the [ __ ] are they look at
all these [ __ ] in here
iced remember sitting in my living room
but alone emerged a german girl that was
beautiful and her and i on friday she
was two years older than me and she had
a boyfriend to Miami so [ __ ] me and her
boyfriend were friends and we did that
on Friday so she would come over
eventually we made out or something
things I'm sure cuz it always goes that
way you remember what's happening that
was my favorite what's happening oh the
white shadow about basketball yeah that
was and these were all shows it's funny
Jerrod Carmichael had a show a
short-lived show on NBC but but I really
enjoyed and it was I really enjoyed the
guy from in living color on it he was
great
Tiffany Haddish was great but what I
really liked about the Jerrod Carmichael
show so that had to do with issues of
what was going on right now today you
know that's what was going on in the 70s
people were moving on up like I always
tell people on from North Bergen New
Jersey but I'm really from
Volken because if people I grew up with
who all from Hoboken they were people
who moved on up to North Bergen or the
house they moved adamite element and
lost Bergen was the new thing to move up
to so North Bergen resort Irish and
Italian
I can't imagine when I moved into the
block and then like there's a new spec
kid on the block so I understood all
this time oh [ __ ] I got it it's tough
now cuz like I grew up and I'm time when
this wasn't allowed like I've heard
stories like Jews not allowed into
country clubs and I've heard stuff like
that before but I never really
experienced that when I grew up everyone
was I guess it was like the start of the
PC world or whatever you want to call it
but it doesn't it doesn't hurt my
feelings but I can see like if you grew
up in it maybe it's something you're
just know like it's you're used to but I
can't imagine not being able to move
into a neighborhood because they're not
gonna like the Jews are living there
it's like that's a weird thought to have
yeah but that's how it was I mean that
it was well even Trump what got in
trouble with his dad because they
wouldn't rent to black people like you
know what I mean like it was completely
like that it was very and III I guess
it's interesting now looking at like
Boston there's this part called
Dorchester where it's a lower income
area there's a lot of black people there
now but when my mom's parents were
moving to the area there was all Jewish
people so it's interesting how like
sometimes I'm like why do all these
Jewish people what are all these Chinese
people live together and it's like maybe
that's the only place they had to live
and now they have a little area but it's
it's just something that we never really
have to think about at all
one day my great you know like that's
very interested in the migration it was
really great and I did the 23andme and
you and tell you we're talking about I
was dating this Asian guy right and so
Joey would always be like you going out
with the toys and the DOS and now I'm
like what the [ __ ] is a toys and it goes
like that was the name we called Asian
people when I was a kid Chinese people
and then I was I was like shut off that
so [ __ ] up and then he's does he
answer
New York 23 me and he's like I'm 2% I'm
like oh my god you a toisan
and then you justify that you said that
the Chinese way before Columbus took a
tour around there's also I read a book
once where the there was a great Armada
as a Chinese Empire fell that had gone
out like as it would go out for like
three to seven years or whatever and
that they went all the way around the
world and it'd be like a lot of ships
together you know Narada and so if a
ship crashed you know they would take
him on but as soon as they hit land the
they had to go on the land and then they
would just kind of you know meld into
the people that were there and that
genetically that's why that they can
tell and say Asian like that makes
complete sense because they probably
went all the way around and we're up and
Kidd they went all the way around and
and they had certain types of chickens
that genetically tests like that are in
South America are Asian you know have
some kind of Asian component and they
say that's part of it and it's
interesting when you start thinking
about history like that you know know
and especially your history like I ended
up well I always knew cuz the Cuban
history you know I always knew that the
island was originally Indians Columbus
came and then the slave trade and then
people from Spain went there after a war
and you had this big [ __ ] and galosh
of people Irish went there during the
Battle of the Boyne so you had all this
you know just like anything else there
was a big Jewish community and like I
couldn't believe how big the Jewish
community was that well in Cuba they
have a big Chinese community right
biggest Chinatown in the world from
China until 1960 or something something
just outrageous someone Bourdain went he
went for the Chinatown though it's not
John it down along like all the Chinese
left you know
there's only one left now that we've
discussed there's only one Cuban Chinese
cook left oh really
and he's on 77th 79th Street and
Broadway my Caridad there's even a video
bottom on YouTube he's the last guy left
right that's it oh that when I was a kid
they were probably five of those Chinese
keeping restaurants in the area
now they down to one how crazy must have
been moved to a different country like
now might be a little bit easier but
like I'm like third or fourth generation
maybe even more I don't know about you
Felicia but Joey humming you're you
emigrate like immigrated from a
different country that's it must be
terrifying it must be like I don't think
I can even understand what it's like I
don't think that it was just terrifying
because of my age that's true right
yeah it wasn't really a thought like if
if I really really really really sit and
think if you ask me anything about Cuba
there's nothing I remember except
looking at the ocean one day and I
remember driving with my dad in a car
like that but I was some women driving
through the Lincoln Tunnel like that
sitting in the driver's seat with no
seat belt you know and you could still
try like I still I have more memories of
my dad in the United States than I do in
Cuba you know I got all of that [ __ ] I
won't be going to kindergarten and the
language barrier like I was telling
Felicia well that was a kid I wouldn't
eat chocolate till nighttime and people
could want to eat chocolate like no
messes because that's what it says
chocolate late-late yes that was five I
would always save chocolate for the
nighttime yeah what are you doing
because it's chocolate late you know
like all those things that may seem
interesting that's why I'm always I try
to be nice to people but extra nicer to
him
it's because I remember those two or
three year window how insecure I felt
and it wasn't just the insecurities I
tell the jokes on stage that it really
bothers me to tell this joke when I say
it about that time period I was allergic
to maple syrup mm-hmm I was a really
sickly kid so it wasn't bad enough that
I was sickly now it was an immigrant
solace to this little with these full of
white kids on 88th Street I was this
[ __ ] speck pariah that was always
with bandages or but you know I always
had bandages on my arms and getting
blood drawn so like not only are you new
which is scary yeah your Spanish
couldn't speak Spanish yeah and I was
[ __ ] sickly that [ __ ] destroyed
and my dad had died mm-hmm
so my mom said every time the door
opened you would look at the door rang
you know so I was just a [ __ ] mess
but I still remember like I don't think
somebody made fun of me I think somebody
said I was an American and in my mind I
was like you know what [ __ ] you I proved
he I'm an American I'm gonna eat hot
dogs like I still remember thinking
mm-hmm if I had enough hot dogs I'd be a
[ __ ] American like things like that
did your mom already speak English when
she came over here just say yes another
man suggested no my mom my mom spoken
this one it was convenient to it okay
she spoke as good as English as you
could well it was convenient there yeah
well it wasn't convenient to her she
played it off so it got to the point
where she wanted me to speak English
outside the house inside the house I had
to speak Spanish she wanted and she
encouraged for me to learn English and
keep the Spanish which I didn't want to
well I think about your mom all the time
like how strong and strong-willed she
must have been to be able to go through
that period of time as an immigrant you
know as a single mother as someone who
is working in an industry that is not
ladylike
you know how she just
that's pretty amazing you know it's not
that part of her life that intrigued me
about my mother
it's 1955 through 1961 or two which is
the most intriguing part of me that I
wish there was a way I knew everything
that happens mm-hmm
because it was just a mess like the
warrant are going to the Bronx are
meeting somebody on the street and them
getting jobs as runners you know for a
bookmaker on the label and then the
bookmaker has a heart attack and then
the ones that know how to do it like you
know it's like Lee is smart he knows
that the cops are looking for male
brothers it's 1950 [ __ ] five in the
Bronx he knows they're looking for male
runners so he enlists two
sixteen-year-old cute girls to run the
numbers room well guess what the guy
gets some type of heart attack so guess
who has to run his business these two 17
or 18 year old girls now and then we had
him move their way and keep it quiet
because if the neighborhood found out
that Lee was sick they wouldn't pay the
girls girls would get so they had to
figure out a way these two girls and the
you know I don't know the whole story
but that's the store then somewhere on
my mind she met my father went back to
Cuba and had my sister and me and then
they were in New York you know they met
in New York and like a weirdest [ __ ]
way my uncle didn't know he goes she got
to New York and bam a year later they
were hooked up together and then he was
doing his thing she was doing her thing
and I didn't like he goes did you know
your mom lived in Venezuela what no I
did not know that
like my uncle told me was yeah she was
in Venice all over your father for six
months Wow he lived in color come on
cacao curse now Peru South Village it
goes out for six more right they were
like to [ __ ] and
then they what do you think they were
doing like what's your guess that you
know what were they do cuz they didn't
have a lot of money right they were
investing the money from the numbers
they were making nobody really knew of
the money my mother was making from
those numbers it was and then they
opened up a sandwich shop across the
street from a Grammar School in Union
City right next to the bar of the guy
that had the big dick I told this club
38 it's an appliance store now it's like
I had refrigeration but in the 50s they
have a sandwich stronger than me okay
and it was up to block for me the
Washington school or something in Union
City then they sold that and what the
bar the whole time they were doing
numbers but my father had a secret
business the heroin business with these
Jews and the Lower East Side him and a
gay guy named angel would take the
Connecticut in sugar heroin to
Connecticut and [ __ ] like that and
that's how they were really making that
money well so they had this bar business
but the same thought my father was a
committee met he was a Cuban committee
man well he was the first Cuban
committee man in university are you
serious
yes oh wow so that's why when he died it
was such a mystery they had to get him
out before he did an autopsy to reveal
the drug use because the politicos
weren't involved on it so it's kind of
[ __ ] up how it all went down like
those are the years how old do you think
she was at this time my mom yeah
30-something g36 maybe cuz yet I was
three
so she died when I was 15 so 12 48 minus
12 is 136 36 but she was 36 and she
picked off like I was saying to her why
do we move from the house in Jersey she
was like when somebody dies you move
that's it I feels like we I didn't want
to live in Jersey anyway I hated Jersey
to be in New York
those that era really don't want to know
what happens those years those are the
years that have always intrigued me
about it I still remember the dry
cleaner I still remember her going with
her the different banks like let's say
she had her own bank but Felicia had her
back
my mother's bank was in Studio City or
Felicia's Bank was in Sherman Oaks even
though on paper we should be kinda
enemies we're fighting for the same
nickel my mother didn't look at it that
way so every day's I'd go to your bank
with my mother we go over then you'd be
surrounded by 12 guys yelling numbers
and write them on a blackboard go get
three pounds of lobsters and [ __ ] them
whatever let's celebrate the Norbit you
know like we used to go to different
banks and see how they ran them God
knows were good and went down alive you
know Wow
but I would see how she wouldn't
maneuver a man in now you know it was it
was like disrespect she was a woman and
she was making her own money in this
woman's in this men's world you know and
then when she got the bar I got to see
how guys would treat her at night like
she she never let her slip up like she
was one of those women that always like
she never let her slip up like it never
got to point B she would [ __ ] never
you on point a check you so [ __ ] hard
that you would just [ __ ] your [ __ ]
pants how you would just go okay and
then 20 people would stare you down and
go what were you thinking
well like it was that type of
men came out the world or something and
I like that I like that style she would
just shut that [ __ ] down like I still
run was different like one night this
guy hit me because I said something to
him and she found out that he kicked me
and my mom asked me did he [ __ ] kick
a girl yeah but I called him like a
[ __ ] half a [ __ ] does that mean he
can't be kicking little son of mine she
picked up the phone and she was saying
[ __ ] to this guy that she goes you know
before you hit my son does what you need
to do you need to go get a guy to put a
big dick up your ass and [ __ ] you and
then you carry that kid for nine months
and then you spit it out of your [ __ ]
[ __ ] you little miserable [ __ ]
don't let me see you without me she was
just going off on this guy she scared
the [ __ ] out of this guy this guy like
closed his mechanic shop like this until
[ __ ] yeah and totally smoothes it out
like it was just a weird thing to see
right but when she was younger and lived
in Cuba how did she go to the United
States the first time it was like going
to any City I remember flying in the
Andes oh when I explain the people
walking in the eighties when I was at
the beginning of my career flying quite
a bit and you would always try to get
the cheapest ticket so there was this
guy that had his office travel agent
down by the airport right down the
corner this guy you would fly and you
would fly under 106 different names
because he would finagle like when
people couldn't get that where they
could make the fly it Bubba blah they
would like source it to him so you would
pay like you know 100 bucks or the lease
is yeah you would fly and then there
were celebrities that did it too and
then it stopped because one side of
celebrity comic I can't remember it was
like Jackie Mason or something like that
someone recognized that that his name
didn't match his ticket I don't know if
it was Jackie Mason but it was something
like that
and then that's when things started to
change when that came but it was awesome
because you can get the cheapest tickets
I just remember going to an airport
going what
they fly like there was no harm line lay
like hold on what's the next flight to
Vegas
tick-tick-tick Burbank Vegas did none of
that and you held like going the yellow
pages and call me hold your line and hi
this is Mel welcome the head I think all
the Florida I'm flying out of Burbank
what time hey they well what do you got
and they pay in this like how do you pay
for it or you pay for it two hours
before flight time yes he's going to the
airport Lee with a cache of money or a
check or a credit card
diners club that's it you traveled under
and you could pay there was no I deeply
I could go to airport and go what's your
name Pablo Escobar okay your tickets 300
mr. Escobar Pam and that was it they
took your word for it how do you spell
Escobar there was no [ __ ] no TSA
there was a guy with a [ __ ] thing
that you went through anyway that's it
or how about no cell phones how about
that traveling with no cell phones how
about that remember that I remember that
I'm not that young I still remember like
when I was a kid my brother and I got by
we had bikes and we were old enough to
go away from the house we didn't have
cell phone we had a my mom got like
these long-range walkie-talkies that
would go like five or six miles and we
had I remember her carrying those around
yeah but I well growing up I had
silverware with American Airlines on a
like actual silverware then my dad or
mom must have taken off the flight or
something like they had actual
silverware for meals no they gave you
flighting was completely different
I told you I still remember going into
an airplane bathroom and there would be
perfuse perfume hand creams for free you
know they were planes that were too
Decker's there were double-decker plays
so first class was upstairs there was a
guy playing a piano [ __ ] and there'd
be a [ __ ] it was crazy watch if you
watch the movie with DeNiro and that guy
that he has to take him cross-country
midnight
remember daddy go upstairs yeah played
the double deck easily at first classes
upstairs and I was a pig without
appellants mother and you'd come over
and take a piece of the pig and [ __ ] Wow
have you ever been on a plane where
they're moving a convict from what form
one city to the other so that is weird
that and and then one time happened to
me but they were sitting right behind me
but it was so it's like so paranoia you
know I am bit on the point and put those
people and I've always heard Joey joke
about that when you do Expedia or
something but they they don't have like
regular planes for criminals it's like
they have a car there but for quick
trials and [ __ ] like that like for a
witness wheel okay the guys I would say
you're a witness we located a guy and
you're in Indiana but your court cases
in New York they won't fly you direct
don't fly you from Indiana it's a
Michigan Tim from Michigan to San
Francisco then you stay at then you go
for the San Francisco to Oklahoma
then Oklahoma in New York City I got the
whole load down and why did they do that
just so nobody's on your tail you don't
know where you're going uh-huh it's so
weird yeah when you're in the witness
relocation plan you don't know where
you're going to an out before you're
leaving when they hand you your ticket
and your dossier of what school your
son's gonna go into it what's his name
gonna be and you know that sounds
terrible I get lonely only yeah I saw it
ever just watched my name is Earl so I
saw them and go through it I can't
imagine it's dealing yeah you're moving
to Nebraska on your name's Joe now and
you can't tell anybody you can't contact
anybody do you know anyone that ever
went under the witness protection
program
Sally BOTS yeah Sally BOTS I met him
here in Studio City he lived around the
corner from here helps oh really and it
was very interesting because you grow up
you know with this code that you'll
never submit you'll never act
you know you know I've never ratted I
never would I don't believe I don't know
but it's crazy when you actually rat
like I don't I always want to know the
reasons you know and I like to figure
him out
you know with Sal Lubitz it's a very
interesting exploring he was gonna get
20 years for heroin he fell had done the
20 years standing on his head south
[ __ ] 78 and he just got married a
month ago I gave one of those guys he
looks great
he's in great shape but what people
don't know about Sal was that wood Sal
was going through all that [ __ ] with
John Gotti he had two sons that were
[ __ ] college heavy duty prospect like
they were in high school and [ __ ]
colleges were already look at these two
guys alright
like big-time help so here's the story
when he got flipped you know he thought
about his kids and he ratted on Jon Kyl
and he took his kids to Texas and change
their names and I mean it was took the
government all out because they were
looking for the boys that's how God he
was gonna find them through the boys so
they had to switch their names and put
them in different high schools and
different [ __ ] parts of Texas and
guess what they both got scholarships
Division Awards oh really
[ __ ] you are they still played one
primarily the University of Colorado in
Boulder oh really
all those years when I was living in
Boulder Sallu boxes up the corner in
North Boulder yeah that's what we hit
off after we met son wet and then he
played pro football so now south when I
just spoke to sow a week ago he's in
Vegas and he got approached by a writer
now you got a little deal para mom or
somebody threw him a little deal and
they got a right destroy his sons so but
somewhat to leave the witness protection
program when do you get to leave
yeah like sorry if he's telling you this
and we're talking about
met him he was already gone from the
program he was still had contact with
the handlers we shot a horrible movie
called the Sinatra Club and when they
got to the set not only was the FBI
there was at what Henry Hill was there
drunk you know just he was just a
[ __ ] loser [ __ ] you know yeah like
when you met Henry Hill Henry Hill is
like 70% of the people in Hollywood oh
they did something one time but they
blew it up into something else you know
you could tell Henry Hill was just a
half a mutt like and even South said to
me goes one time when I first got into
the program
I got a lot a job working as an
apartment building manager and I got a
hold the Henry Henry lived in Venice or
the valley or whatever and I invited him
over and he when he were drinking coffee
he saw the apartment keys to all the
apartments they stopped all of you
around the apartment sees Henry a 50
cent really and like Henry was still
like he was just a [ __ ] the thug that
got to to tell his story first then the
bunch of people wrote that book saying
that guy was crazy but Scorsese
Baltimore so nobody could deter from his
story primarily the daughter Henry Hills
daughter wrote a great book and she was
like how can you believe the guy that
was high he married listen Henry Howe
was so crazy there's a part in my Blue
Heaven with Steve Martin goes into the
phase a mafia guy who ever seen that
movie like brilliant movie but there's a
scene where he calls his handler and he
goes hey Benny I got married say hello
and he goes but Vinnie you're already
married he goes don't worry uh I married
her under my other name Henry hell at
one time was married to his wife in the
same house in Washington State he was
married to his wife and she lives in the
building in the basement and he was
married to a young chick upstairs his
witness relocation they
and that's what I told his wife cuz what
are you talking about it's not cheating
I married her under my witness name but
in his criminal [ __ ] demented alcohol
cocaine mind he thought that was like
fun like so did the two women know about
each other in the same house you know
[ __ ] turned over thought he got busted
in Washington mm-hmm and then all this
[ __ ] went down but you know you it's
like the most interesting guy in the
world to me the last 20 years like I
find a lot of people screaming why is
interesting but I like when somebody
makes something out of nothing
yeah those who people are impressed the
[ __ ] out of me whether it's a woman with
a avon company is something whatever is
a gamma he just got in jail Sammy the
bull just got out of jail I would pay to
have him on the podcast to pick his
business mind apart and to pick after 30
years why he ratted and I guarantee that
he'd say that I'd write I'd write then
why here at and give it to him he go how
did you know yeah because I thought
about it he had to get to them before
they got to them you follow me sometimes
it's better to get your story out faster
before he tells us exactly when the
tapes first came out it made the tape
sound like he was crazy Sammy the bull
Gravano I'm like God he was just talking
all this [ __ ] about him meanwhile he was
making 12 million dollars a [ __ ] here
by giving you 12 million dollars a year
off his construction rackets when I give
you a million a month off my
construction rackets do you know how
much money I'm making 10 million a month
so you have to understand that guy
figured out how to become I mean hey
this is why I never understood why trunk
beside the politics and the elections
and the wig and the bad
and the Russians I never understood how
Trump got elected because in Sammy's
book he talked all about Trump
yeah it was the construction business it
was the construction business well I
remember you telling me about it when it
was during the election way before the
election I told the people I'm Mike he
mentioned that in the book and then she
came out and said I hope Trump wins
because maybe he'll pardon my dad
they're all friends she said it the
daughter said it on Entertainment Weekly
as they would that's the construction
his construction and he gives the story
how he would shake Trump down how are
you Sheikh they are building them
Felicia Michaels is building a [ __ ]
tremendous new building in New York
everything a [ __ ] room he could pick
up a wall and Al Franklin tickles your
balls oh my cute tiny little ball so you
have this loan from the bank you have to
pay this [ __ ] loan back you borrow
two hundred million dollars you know
your Vig is every [ __ ] month so
construction has to [ __ ] be on call
like constant like they got to keep
moving like there's an article now that
came a baby was playing those poor poll
dogs $4 an hour
oh by moving the Sopranos when they
would give a membe elopes
okay by union law I gotta have 30
laborers on at $18 an hour you know what
18,000 hours that's $18 for [ __ ] also
workman's comp so if I pay you 18 you
really costing me [ __ ] 36 plus the 10
for the union [ __ ] so that's 36 and
10 is 46 from an infant Felicia Michaels
46 dollars a [ __ ] hour or whatever
the [ __ ] it is plus I got a [ __ ] give
her a 15-minute break leather scratch
your ass smoked a cigarette [ __ ] you so
what they do is they take the 30
laborers and they take 15 of them they
actually pay them
but then they take 15 poor souls and
they pay them non-union wage and they
pocket the union wages and that's who
LeMond forgets to pay back from so you
have if you have 15 [ __ ] guys and
you're saving $40 $40 an hour that's a
lot of Labor [ __ ]
that's a lot of alright so they would
that's what they do
well why do you think people see past
that money I don't know I see people pay
past that because I'm very confused on
what's going on lately and what happens
we forgive we forgive as Americans we
have to forgive as human beings I know
but we always forgive after we really
super set someone on fire and it just
seems like he puts he makes so many
fires were so distracted I always said
this and you get that no talking about
right now about right now I'm talking
about 15 20 years ago all the little
actions that he did that you know like
the Trump thing I mean I said it and two
weeks later the Washington journal
review who had a write up about it
Trump official ties to Sammy the bull
head Philadelphia he bought that
property directly from the Philly mob
you know like there's like you know and
nobody can it was forgotten about you
know we also live in a society that
glamorizes mafia you know we why did we
love Sinatra so much because he could
sing no because he rubbed out what was
his people he was cool
yeah that one [ __ ] black Jew other
guys the glamorization you know if I
come to you tomorrow and say I cheated
on Terry with some chick I don't think
you talked to me for a while but Tony
Soprano does every week to his wife man
and you can wait there was a soprano and
that
time did you look at me and say he's a
fat [ __ ] little cheater
actually I wouldn't say anything to
Terry I would say to you get your [ __ ]
together stand trying to say to you that
I know it's how we look at different
situations right you know right now
we're living in a country right now I
could say to you
Felicia I have to pass something to you
gonna say what you know and I did The
Longest Yard I was putting my football
pants on one day the hell it was hey I
rub my nutsack
and you'd say to me so did you say they
know he's Alabama was gonna believe did
you enjoy it what was it like you know
but I also have to go to my also before
I open my mouth it says in my a little
while has he been convicted of it again
like it's funny you and I had this
conversation a month ago and I thought
about it now I understand where we were
coming from why people come out
afterwards right because that I felt
very strongly of like that's right okay
you come out right away or whatever but
I need a win awesome when they were
sitting and he has a few drinks and he
goes that I would tell you that day no
long as you're I'm telling trying to
finger it up my ass there in the shower
saying and now we got a problem
yeah cuz now he did the two of us and
now we'll both go public you know at the
same time I always think about what I
was doing
20 years ago and what I'm doing today
mm-hmm and I could look you in the eye
and say I've completely change that like
I don't see a lot of that I used to see
before like that low-end vine as you
call it criminal so I can't eat are you
with me on that's like it's it's rough
for a guy like me if you said to me two
weeks ago I went to a comedy show and
somebody fingered me in the back we got
a [ __ ] problem you know what Joey I
was just having lunch with Jackie
Kashian
and a bunch of comics and there was a
young guy comic that was defending girl
comics about how new be girl comics are
afraid at night at the clubs and I was
all like why never and then someone
brings up Louie and I was literally like
I was around Louie for a long time and
he never did anything to me and so I am
suspect and then all the stuff came out
and you think and you start to realize
you know people that are predatory are
picking people that no one will believe
you know what I mean that they're gonna
pick some people that if you heard
something to be though that girl's
questionable or I don't believe you or
this or that you know and I just think
that there needs to be a clear
conversation of what we're gonna
tolerate as a society you know like like
if a guy hits on me while I'm at work
you know that what is the rule like what
are the rules we need to have that
conversation so like one part of me is
like Al Franken must be a creeper but
then the other part of me is like
wouldn't it be great if someone like
that could really have a conversation
like start a conversation of what is
acceptable and what is not acceptable
you know because I think a lot of people
are getting called out righteously and I
think I worry about because I heard a
girl come and say oh now
Booker's aren't gonna book girls because
they don't want to freak the guys out
you know II mean they'll go underground
it's like all this [ __ ] like this just
have a real conversation about it I
don't want this to be like for girls a
handicap bathroom for kind
right now two girls can't get hired
because the guys in the condo I don't
want everybody should man it's you know
what I've shared thousands of condos
it's uh
I never you know man
what's the word you use predatory yeah
I've never been predatory with my hands
no when I used to get coked up the coke
would make me be predatory with my mouth
right so you talk some [ __ ] I would
don't want some [ __ ] but my cells and
[ __ ] [ __ ] skills also get enlightened
you know are you good at it when I was
coked up yeah
I could talk to you in the [ __ ]
anything and you were on the fence if
you were a little coke if you like the
room look Oh getting fingered I could
get you half way that feeling was I and
I'm the type of guy that I never wanted
no surprise cuz I never I was such an
addict that don't think you're gonna
come to my hotel room snort coke I only
saw that suck a dick I'd do something
like that okay just loading the cocaine
we're family even if tomorrow we're back
to being friends so that you gotta suck
a little dick show me that monkey gonna
do some I would set it up before we went
through the hotel uh-huh so the girl
knew exactly what was that about with
Tootsie those when we get there and I
put you to work a little bit what do you
mean you know you gonna show me the
monkey we got to do something okay
you know the deal people do the deal go
ahead so you have to be at like I was
you know like what are you doing you
said would never do you ever even worry
about saying stories like that because
I'm sure there's people that hear that
that could interpret that differently
I'm not saying I'm telling you from an
addicts perspective right I'm not
telling you from a Joe Diaz perspective
during the the coke key is like I was
telling the story at dinner about
something you know somebody saved my
life tonight sugar bear
we tell you [ __ ] [ __ ] up storing you
know part this story I didn't feel you
know the whole [ __ ] story because I
didn't remember at the time we talked on
the phone her alive meantime the time
and we giggling with dear friends I was
if I'm 54 she's 52 but she was hard when
I was 15 and she was 13 I used to have
an above-ground pool and when I was
about 14 everybody would come along with
a pool that God was armed with that you
know when you're 14 there's a start
reacting to women you know and I was
swimming underneath and I saw her going
and he him that she went up her bikini
went down a little bit she had the hairy
his [ __ ] in the world and my body just
froze in the water I thought I was in a
[ __ ] drown but she was like kind of
like a little sister type along with her
brother and we all got together and this
just nothing happened Felicia we were
tight and guess what my mother dies yeah
my mother dies November 8th and it's
Christmas even I felt terrible inside
Felicia I mean I didn't know what I felt
like I just can't describe the feeling
like and we spoke on the phone and we
will [ __ ] how you have it
even though mean you how about weird
things man yeah Karen I walked out
because I had to tell her what happened
I go I was with my friends we got
knowledge at Daniel's and we went out I
bumped into you at that party she goes I
remember and I go what I was [ __ ]
mine [ __ ] you I wasn't and I was
doing hope that night how is mine
[ __ ] her from a friend from us from
the angle of pain I just didn't know how
to tell her I did not want to be alone
that night right
I did not want to be alone I had never
really had sex with a girl before and
nothing would make me feel better
tonight so if I could have sex with you
and I told it just like that felishj I
go even if he just come over and let me
suck your titties I don't even know how
I said it wasn't really in a vulgar way
and I told you I went back she said no
that she was still too young to lose her
virginity and I'm like totally destroy
that I went back like jumped the fence
and I drank at the grave the rest of the
Jack and I kept thinking maybe I should
dig my mother up I mean I I felt
horrible at night like it was the first
Christmas away something I can't even
imagine how my Chung's offense and I
cried the whole walk home and when I
walked in the [ __ ] house the phone
was ringin and it was her
it's just what are you doing like oh I
just got home you know and she goes are
you gonna be home for a while
oh yes she came over 15 minutes later
and we made love and till this day we're
best friends and I finally called her
two weeks ago and explained to her when
she left how I felt like it gave me a
lease on life is stupid this selfish why
she she was an angel at my chain she
didn't come over and was I still have
her bleeding in us me holding her like I
had never done that before she lost her
virginity like I had never done none of
this stuff before and I remember her
leaving like we didn't sleep at all that
night the people were living we just
coming home they were playing cards on
losing it and like that gave me another
three months of life like it wasn't just
a piece of [ __ ] like in I'm saying
right my mother died that chick did give
me a piece of charity [ __ ] she calling
a week out my mother wasn't the dirt
wasn't even stiff yet and this chick was
an old good piece of ass from the old
days I had never made love to before
he's two-fingered weed
remember he's 15
it's just thinking how many [ __ ]
different [ __ ] stories I know of
your I was such a Catholic that I would
dare to put my dick in your [ __ ] like I
would rather look at no I wouldn't even
look at it I just
I bring you through your pants I even
got caught one finger the German girl a
father is watching me fingering it they
told her company she couldn't move cuz
my hand were in her pants she's like
five minutes on my hair five minutes
pops okay they transferred her but she
was a Holy Rosary Academy the next day
they put a like in [ __ ] jupiter hotel
we Christians up there but it was funny
because when she left that man like it
was oh no I was telling you about the
other guy gave me a piece it's telling
her she had a piece for me she had never
made love to me I think it doesn't have
a barbecue scene your story in three
minutes that's all I did I used to just
finger them at barbecues that one I
think another barbecue would jump
benders house tablecloth over it you do
it outside
no I did it inside at the four seasons
yeah the outside no I got the room at
the four seasons what I'm 40 yet the
[ __ ] do you think this is Rosa where you
know my mother you know it is to bring a
girl in a Cuban listen here's the weird
thing like Felicia I love you to death
but if you're Spanish these
conversations we have about your boys
would not exist you would sit them down
and go here there's plain and simple
yeah the first [ __ ] I see in here she's
going to hospital didn't you're gonna
toss it
that's our Spanish Bob's off like you
punk going to hospice for broken bones
and other damages don't bring one of
your skinny [ __ ] over here Cuban
Cuban moms do not play like I used to
try for a while my mom used to make me
leave the door
whatever you did but we're trying to
study we can't hear with your music I'll
put the music down but leave that
[ __ ] door open and if a girl called
the house god forbid my mother would
have Tara gate it but I did I did that
to Joey with my sons and I had I don't
know if I told you this but I had done a
gig where they were giving it at a gay
club where they were giving out condoms
so I had like I opened my person
literally poured him in and then I gave
15 of them to each of the the kids and
then like two weeks later my oldest is
like we're going to the drugstore he's
like mom you got any more of those
condoms I'm like what the [ __ ] dude I
bought you 15 condoms I told you not to
mess around I mean like I use them and
then I go what I go with who and he goes
with these two different chicks and I go
when and he goes when you were home and
I'm like we're in my room and the door
was open
that's how fast it happens Joey that's
and I had to say to him don't have sex
over here you know why your son's in
there get grounded I can't have judgment
on ACCA's because now his bedroom is
where we used to do the old podcast
where I took a picture of your balls
very straight face - I want to take away
he didn't take a picture my balls and
you looked at mooing hell let me get my
camera hold my dick up while you took my
balls it was funny because at first
she's trying some eight feet away I had
to get up on that [ __ ] you're like wait
a second this is like Vietnam I gotta
get up close and [ __ ] do you mind if you
try to do that now like and with all
this stuff happening if you got that
call today Felicia or back that I was
thinking my son let's say a girl wants
to get it again I'm not being fresh with
anybody on this
if a woman wants to get her cuz I see
all these women I see all these women
like I'm a [ __ ] sexual something is
talking about pierced vaginas I thought
I want to call that biggest vagina has
really got but in 2015 it was the year
the PFC jo Assumption everybody got
their vaginas peers and I was thinking
about like who pierces vaginas women or
men I think Bo I think it depends on who
you go to I guess they're a doctor or
those a tattoo do do this I don't know
maybe they just get a potato and a
needle do it themselves can you imagine
where they appears like the clip I don't
[ __ ] know you know I didn't ask the
New York Times you know where the [ __ ]
it is no I'm kind of scared I don't know
what that in my [ __ ] history my wife
goes in this and next thing you know I'm
[ __ ] you know it's uh whose fault is
that isn't mine right normally ain't
know me
ain't nobody called his mother [ __ ]
Jesus Christ
but it is it is weird how like different
like you can be okay with different
things like Joey you say all these
things we've joked for years like how
you talk to the Denny's waitresses and
it's not even anything sexual but it's
just something that you wouldn't expect
like women to be okay with so it I I
think it would be kind of hard to know
what the line is for some people
well that's a thing it's like after the
whole Louie I think came out some girl
come a young girl comic put on there I
wouldn't care Louie showed me his Pino
whatever and and yeah that's cool for
you but that's might not be for
everybody I mean you don't know what
experience people have had you know like
if you're going around masturbating in
front of some chick that was molested as
a kid or had an issue or even if you
know like why don't we even have to
endure that you know I try I'm crazy
Felicia I know I have moments about
[ __ ] crazy listen I thought about it
you know I've been thinking a lot lately
I've been doing a lot of soul-searching
just like the Jean a story with the door
a14 and [ __ ] like that like I always
thought about that story the wrong way
she was an angel that night she really
did saved me I don't remember the sex I
don't know what acts we did I came in a
minute doesn't matter always been a
preemie I just know that I felt
different after that I'm not that
Concord I sometimes you have sex and you
feel like a conqueror this wasn't a
conqueror this was like she had given me
three months I swear to god it's the
weirdest I think it's a beautiful story
and I don't think that equates at all
even though you were you know talking
her in but you know yeah yeah but even
though you were talking her in I think
that's a beautiful story and that was a
very kind thing that she did but that's
a way different than you know what stuff
is going on like what about that Matt
Lauer thing how weird to wake up and
hear
what exactly did Madeline work there's
just as far as I know they were saying
that someone that worked there they had
some meeting and some big story came out
about how he I guess was harassing
someone however I don't know the details
I don't know the details about I read an
article that drew before you guys came
over that he had a button and his desk
that could remotely lock the door so no
one could come in oh yeah but was he
using it to do the stories haven't
really come out yet from what I heard is
that he had a reputation like one time
he had a producer bring a pillow up to
his room that he he thought was pretty
so just but it's a weird because I grew
up I started out in post-production and
it's different for me like it's it's not
a sexual thing but there's a little bit
it's like it is kind of a boys club
there's a little bit of hazing a little
bit there's a so does do you think stuff
like this even though like it you
obviously it's terrible what's happening
you have to report it do you think it's
hurting women in a way almost so it's um
that everything is coming out right now
just that in some ways I think it would
scare some people from hiring or
bringing in women well you always worry
about that but the fact is like why
should we have to be your lesson
like why for Lois to learn the lesson of
not to do that why do those women have
to endure that
I mean fishermen they shouldn't yeah the
whole thing is but then what are the
rules it goes back to what are the rules
I mean as far as if you're at work and
you're in an editing Bay and you can you
ask a girl out is that considered
harassing you know like what is then
what is it gonna be like where you can't
even ask other people out because that
you know there has to be a line so no is
that a line is asking somebody out a
line what if you're working with someone
in a work place do you think you know
especially if it's a corporation I think
some corporations have rules about that
but and I've heard I've heard some
people like he would continue asking
people out which is would freak people
out I guess
but I don't think like one asking on the
dates the thing i i'm just even thinking
about like stupid like farts or dick
jokes or just like i don't know i don't
know where the line is with that like I
don't know like that there's this guy
who I'm still very friendly with who
would come up behind me and just start
rubbing my shoulders or just I was a 23
year old kid getting he freaked me out
and we would laugh and but I can see
with a girl it'd be a very different oh
absolutely
be a very different situation because
that's some guys that's how they get
into it about oh I'm really good at
giving a massage oh really you're gonna
give me a platonic massage right here in
the horrible is like please but that's
kind of creepy did you feel creepy when
he did it the first time like I would
just like it was just it was almost like
it was it felt a little weird but it was
a just started laughing it was just I
never I never viewed it as as something
bad and I don't know I did it keep
trying to do it what you would do it
well we would do it he would do it all
the time yeah well then every time I did
it would he just go a little further
like a little hair further a little hair
free you never would touch anything but
he would like he would hug me and like
rattle yeah it was uh and I don't know
it's in a way cuz III can't I can't
imagine what girls go through but I will
part of me doesn't want them to be able
to miss out on that because another's
there's a lot of women who are editors
and working the tech side of things and
it wouldn't be fair really for them to
like not be able to get positions or or
they don't have the same yeah but this
perience the same thing is like Here I
am sitting with Joey and you right and
Joey's talking told me three fingers
storage hooks in a row like if we were
in a corporate atmosphere that wouldn't
be okay but it's but because we're doing
this kind of stuff or you're doing
editing where it's a it's a little bit
more of a relaxed atmosphere there's you
know as a woman when you're joking with
a guy like that when it's cool and when
it's not cool
I [ __ ] hate since I was a young man
to put a [ __ ] facade on for a woman I
would rather not [ __ ] talk to you and
not be around you any woman if I
had to put a [ __ ] facade on because I
had I got called out maybe 30 years ago
you did I got called out by a woman at a
car dealership because she said
including my conversations because I was
trying to be a gentleman
mmm and when they she goes maybe I want
to hear that [ __ ] joke did you ever
think about that
and I felt so shitty because I would
always crack stupid jokes but I would
always pull guys to the side and about
them and she really liked me she was an
older woman if I was 22 she was 40 she
had kids good look at his [ __ ] you know
I'm good-looking husband nice people so
I didn't act the curse and father I was
trying my hardest and one day she came
home and she doesn't answer a question
what don't mean you do I go we do
everything we go she was rocking when
you tell something dirty I'm not invited
I don't know and she does well he don't
think I only had the [ __ ] choke myself
from time to time and why I lost my so
everything I suspected about myself at
that time I throw out the window like
everything my mom taught me growing up
at that point so I've always included
women like an equal I can't tell the
story about anal raping somebody in
front of somebody well if I'm gonna tell
a good dick story or [ __ ] story well
you're a comedian you know again I don't
want to talk about black comics I don't
talk about white cupboards I want old my
German come on I don't like
differentiating comics I put women comic
I love I love everybody I want you just
to be funny so what I'm going to car
with you and we're taking a six-hour
drive on a trimmer one and if you think
me and we have to sit there and be
[ __ ] Mormons because you get offended
right I'm not treating you as a [ __ ]
comedian man right so there's so many
thin lines here that you have to
understand as what we're doing what am I
gonna every time I see a hot chick I'm
gonna look at me and go and you're gonna
sit there like one of my third teaming
and just say that you like her ass guys
you know that's what's part of a
comedian right me taking my clothes off
for you
my digger yeah that's not the right do I
have my bad at Louie in it listen I can
I've never lived in those shoes I need
different shoes I lived in and I'm sure
he heard of the shoes I lived in either
like I'm either so but I think that
that's the other part of I've never
treated you like a second I've always
treated you like one of my brothers and
James I don't give a [ __ ] your feelings
gonna toughen up your [ __ ] talent you
know my friends injuries you don't cut
no corners they don't cut no corners you
don't tell like there are guys you
wouldn't say and tell an anal rape story
to I mean when you're out and about I
wish I did that and have some other time
but we're all the problem too is
sometimes people can't pick up other
signals with people you know like people
and I think like if you're in a
situation we're working together and
then I'm the woman that says that to you
yeah I like a dirty joke it's cool we're
all cool right but then the problem
becomes there are people out in society
that aren't picking up the subtle cues
of just because I'm saying I like a
[ __ ] joke to them they might see her
saying I like [ __ ] jokes is man I don't
like some [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what I mean like people's
filter is all different and that's the
problem like how do we how are we gonna
regulate this whole conversation when
when people don't see things the same
way you know that people has to have a
different filter by the way I mean the
majority of us have the filter of you
know don't [ __ ] where you eat and be
respectful obviously but how do you
regulate the rest of it and and who do
you throw in jail over it and who do you
get rid of over it like what what is the
the line you know do you think Louie can
come back do you think he can come back
is it actual do you think so do you
think a guy like Bill O'Reilly can come
back no yeah this is because it's over
and over and over and he's such a
[ __ ] puke to look at and then he
didn't know he was some type of [ __ ]
before you watch if you know you don't
want like the one who had me fool with
Charlie Rose he looks like
he's just father like I go over then not
even if I dated you know type of dads
like hey hey come on intelligent that's
Charlie Rose to my grow up on Charlie
Rose you know but the [ __ ] dude the
Roy Moore oh he's molested little boy -
he was a Cub Scout leader I got fine I
get rid of teeth I got a dig team that
do is just a dirty [ __ ] freak you
know they look at and it doesn't it
doesn't you know I don't want to judge
but like when you look at Harvey
Weinstein I had heard stuff and when you
look at me good toys a [ __ ] pig I
mean he's just a [ __ ] bag and then
you can't blame the position he's and
you know the position he said he would
do stuff like that
that's what people those type of creepy
that's what's coming on every day every
day's a CEO this you know who I bet is
at home [ __ ] jumpin up and down cause
me right now Cosby's attorneys like this
hold tight we need three more these
white [ __ ] to get caught and
we're gonna get thrown right out of
buggin what can we like falesha can I
ask you like the difference between and
maybe Cosby's not a good example because
he here a people many drag them but was
like Louie the thing that I was thinking
about was at least so far it's always
come out that he asked beforehand and
then like the issue was and at least in
the article that I read is that people
who we asked some but because of who he
was didn't feel like they could say no
or didn't know what happened well you
get paralyzed you don't know what to say
look I was thinking about this when you
were talking about the girl that came
over and you said that you had jumped
into the swimming pool and you seen her
little bushy bushy and I was thinking
and I'm and I'm being completely [ __ ]
serious I was at the mall a week ago and
it was a mom and her daughter who was
like 18 and we were on the escalator and
she had on short shorts and I she had
like her she was it was so bushy it was
like halfway down early and I and I was
paralyzed because when you when you come
up for even if it's that lame and stupid
I was like oh do I say something
don't look don't you know you have that
moment we were just like what do you do
and so when someone says I'm gonna do
this real quick as they're doing that
you're paralyzed and and it's not always
out of this tremendous fear it's just
like what do I owe my job and if I said
Y X how do I back out of this without
losing my job that's what it is and then
that's a problem like that that's a part
that I think and it doesn't justify what
he did at all but if he's been doing
this or if anyone's been doing it for 20
years when they're a normal person and a
girl couldn't say yes or no one wouldn't
be like wouldn't I think there's a job
online or anything but now Louie just
happens to have a TV show and now people
are putting now on him oh now he won't
like me or taking me on the road if I
say no yeah so like that it must be like
that's something that you also have to
think about like okay now I'm Who am I
and can I still do these things because
like I don't I don't work with another
guy who did what we did be in the same
amount of trouble I don't know well I
mean yes you get in trouble you can go
to jail you can get in trouble for that
that's not okay you know the thing is
that when people do stuff like that
they're picking on people that they have
power over you know they're not going
out and doing it at a bar where they're
really vying for the most beautiful
women with seven under other hunky guys
you know they're picking people that
they have a shot with and that and it's
because they're in the position of power
you know it's funny before we go on let
me go to the shoutouts real quick before
I [ __ ] forget because we did a
podcast this week but the [ __ ] hero
is I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
doesn't matter
first off a little thanks Scott
Cunningham for putting the [ __ ] page
back with my man Dickie sigh at VP
operations
I want to thank Cassius Loras jay-z
Michael lose your Oakland Gino Robles
Troy Pierce Jordan Barnett and Ari knows
don't forget son de novo Monday
Observatory San Diego and Tuesday
Observatory
and all you got left is Thursday for
Sacramento and my dates are done for the
year I'm [ __ ] retiring for 2017 I
don't want to 2018 you want I did a
podcast a couple years ago it was a
great talk and it was something I
learned in 1985
I've learned in 83 I went back I got a
call I needed some place to stay and a
girl called me and that we were talking
one day the girl that I had known in
high school
1981 to 1983 in my neighborhood every
boot was [ __ ] everybody you know if
we were Corky's together and we went to
a bar and we did the coke at three if
you went back to the thing we were
[ __ ] and we were friends and then the
next day you'd go out with your
girlfriends and nobody would say
anything and we just move on it was fine
and I came back from Colorado and we did
coke a couple nights like two nights
alone over the Second Life Alicia we
were both in the same bed like we're a
long way in there and something made me
not touch her like I'd turned over a lie
something those days to come down from
coke I would take an orange and take the
guts out and suck on the peel I said
they said that that would bring you down
whatever hey Finn after a lies I moved
on and moved to friends and nothing ever
happened between us and I came and I
always regretted it like [ __ ] that gotta
[ __ ] to that man she's [ __ ] hot piss
and [ __ ]
years went by and something happened and
I had to a beef and she heard about it
she bailed me out she even gave me money
and she was a friend
she helped me stay with her for a few
days and I learned a valuable lesson
that you can't [ __ ] everybody I learned
that lesson at 21 years old you can't
[ __ ] everybody there's nothing more than
when I see a guy over 20 for thinking
that he could [ __ ] everything when
you're 18 you can [ __ ] whatever you want
you can go guys with a thing that
low-class they actually have no idea
they're finding this sexual who the [ __ ]
they are sexually when you're 21
everybody you know those guys are
annoying musicians and you mean them and
you see them that work you and if
there's no the one window give me two
minutes they're working the girl next to
you then you sit down go what the [ __ ]
by the way how come we haven't heard
anything from musicians harassing women
that's got to be the next big chunk of
people coming out well the really
weirdest thing I had was not to go away
from that I'll go back to it because you
don't love this story but that's rule
number one
he just can't [ __ ] everybody you got a
look at some women and oh you know what
she's gonna be a [ __ ] ally you know
she's gonna be this as something [ __ ]
and then if he do take a long
professionally they have to be
professional you have to be professional
you know I've always kind of really
believed in that you have to be [ __ ]
professional man you know who you never
[ __ ] you know
in the [ __ ] when you're on the road you
bump into victims and you know and then
you would go back to your room and you
can't believe [ __ ] happens half the time
you can't believe you ask them late for
a [ __ ] and they suck your dick or you
were doing coke you can't you know but
that that's the main thing about this
like even when you hear Trump's
conversation that Justin on the bus
would Billy Bush or Billy BER whatever
his [ __ ] name is that Justin
that wasn't just Trump that was the
voice of a lot of men that think that
way oh absolutely you have a star you
just broke the Felician grab a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you know that wasn't the
voice of just Trump that's that was the
voice of a lot of men in that position
yeah of entitlement to always thought
entitlement yeah you don't know [ __ ]
Saint but I'm no [ __ ] sinner you know
I've been on both sides of the fence I
just I always kept that in mind it you
can't [ __ ] everybody you can't [ __ ]
everybody why would you want to even
sleep with somebody who's really not
even [ __ ] enjoyed it whatever you
even think I'm happy yeah
why would if asleep put an X you have a
[ __ ] some way for three years but he had
good dick Felician after six months you
go over there for a dose of dick and
it's a dick but how badly do you feel on
the way home
oh yeah it's like killing at addy Club
you're gonna be club you were standing
oh by the way I'll be like I should
shoot myself right it's like you know
I'm saying like I don't want to be with
somebody who doesn't really want to be
with well that's cuz you have learned to
grow your empathy muscle you know and
people that do that don't have aren't
having empathy they're they're unable to
feel sorry or bad for someone else
they're doing it because they're unable
to put themselves in the other person's
shoes
I'm een don't you think if someone's
doing that they're also being a [ __ ]
bully I mean it's like the sexual
component of it is bad enough but that's
a bully personality so you know no nice
guy is like
sorry you mean it's a [ __ ] bully
that's don't like all those guys are
bullies you know it's like I wanna know
the ages that we're sending those girls
to those meetings at a hotel that's the
next thing that's gonna come up it has
to right eventually they have you we
have to shoot the message who sent all
these young girls to the meetings they
knew what the [ __ ] was going on who
hooked up these [ __ ] meetings with
Whitley [ __ ] Harvey how did they find
out about her with Harvey just call
Felicia Michael's up let's just have a
project for you meet me at the Four
Seasons suite 111 I want to know who the
message was hear the message run always
but the thing is it's like this it's the
same thing is if we're on the road what
do we do if you and I go on the road
we're hanging out in your hotel room you
know what I mean like there there is a
lot of normalcy in the business
maybe that's the part that will change
where if someone is living in New York
but working on a project here in LA and
they have a suite in the hotel like
there is an argument to be made for like
it seems kind of reasonable you know in
a way right but then the way he did it
it wasn't like come to my hotel room it
was like come to my let's have lunch
oh let me go get you a script I'll just
walk with me to go get you a script oh
you know what I put the script in my
suitcase I'm not saying this is exactly
how it's all the
Shannon bring the script down come on
let's take a walk up to it and don't
even tell you that's how they suck in
you can wait down here come on I'll show
you this other script I got it's those
little crumbs that they throw at you and
you're like well I don't is this what
guys do doom it because that's the thing
if then we're two guy comics and we're
hanging out in the room right if I'm the
opener and I'm the girl comic and now
two guy commercial I go listen you know
we don't want to get in trouble or
whatever and then you don't get to go in
the room that sucks too because that's
the best part is when everyone's equal
in a private situation and you're having
a great conversation or you're talking
about a project or you know whatever it
is you know so it's it's a complicated
thing you know but I'm sure show bit I'm
sure now show business will change in
that they have to the whole business has
to change and I was talking with John
Fugelsang he's a always is up on
everything and he's like the mainstream
media isn't even reporting how much
sexual harassment is bubbling up in all
businesses like people are getting
called out and all little corporations
it's not just media that but mainstream
media isn't really reportedly the most
about Hollywood situation that they boil
it up Mike Harvey invented and it's been
going on in Hollywood sister [ __ ]
Terry's different abuse and [ __ ]
women
a thousand times that poor that poor
longer you know what but you know what
it is it's like when you do a gig right
and you have a comic friend that's
booking the gig and he's making and the
gig the the venue is giving him for
grant but he's only giving you like 500
he's given the the middle 250 and he's
taking the other 3200 whatever it is or
200 whatever it is it's like that's how
is equated to me about the whole sexual
harassment thing like everybody wants to
take a little cherry on top no one Minds
if you take a little cherry on top of
you're working with someone and you like
that chicken you hit on that chick or
you touch your shoulder and then and
then you know it creeps her out but
nothing is said that's you know okay I'm
not mad that guy it's the people who are
pigs about it it's a people that want to
not just take the cherry on top they
want to [ __ ] you in the ass you know
what I mean
they want to take that you know that's
the it's the bullying mentality of that
though like how do we regulate that
what's the answer for that there's no
regulation of it because like you said
look how many people sixty six people
came out after the fact you know I
guarantee the still got a 50 women that
just don't even want to think about it
how did he even have time to work you
know what like that was a lot of energy
you know what do they do does he read
the script he's got three guys hired
like people to hush the women up like
all that drama that he had to constantly
put out fires just to get his dick
sucked
counterintelligence people to see what
was out there about him and for pay or
UPS you know it's again what a tangled
web we weave right
well we tangled to the sieve I'm in his
you have to sit down at one point and go
isn't that worth it to have really it
was at that important them and this is a
different type of addiction this isn't
coke or how all this is your addiction
to the action of the lie the action of
the whole this is a whole different
[ __ ] thing and let's say I don't know
if he did coke but what would make you
only you know he had so many lawsuits
out there what would make you hire
[ __ ] people to find out what was out
there about something it's brilliant
yeah yeah no the whole thing is just
nuts
you know against the tangled web we
weave and only had to do wait let's go
back to the details going to the [ __ ]
best restaurant in town
find yourself a little pretty girl
talk to a little bit and say look I'm
married I'm 42
me and my wife barely talk I can respect
them what see if she doesn't let me come
there he is anymore
I'd make [ __ ] 5 million a month
well if well if every month I gave you
10 grand you got a brand-new car I come
over twice and but then give you a stab
wound like your [ __ ] I'm fired then I
sign a [ __ ] waiver that's all you
could do and I don't tell me that people
don't do that that way all the [ __ ]
time I know guys you got for those
[ __ ]
really I do a guy years ago I had four
[ __ ] on a payroll did they even sleep
at night like I would how do they even
tolerate all that anxiety over every
moment must be like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
get caught no no no no what court you
mind your [ __ ] business Felicia I
give you five grand you shut your mouth
I come over you suck my dick get a piece
of apple pie I leave here I go [ __ ] your
ass it's none of your business you rent
this pay right the lights of pain you
having a good time dancing and singing
all night right we went out the pool
call asthma did you not suck a dick down
there yeah okay then
these guys just pay for that it's called
peace of mind sex peace of mind sex I
don't want to hear it
and every month I want a report from the
doctor I want you taught my go check on
that little monkey I wanted breaking
down proteins well I was thinking about
you joke is a few months ago you we had
a couple episodes where you were really
interested in like sugar daddy sugar we
were talking about sugar daddy Vegas is
full of them no [ __ ] like I was I was
walking around and there were guys I was
like how did you like even like how like
I would be embarrassed to walk around
and be like the grandpa and like the ate
like the high school senior look like it
was a crazy it's an arrangement it's an
arrangement you were good you
mandus I don't know I got a wife and
three kids out of that time but it's
won't we go to Vegas once a month we're
gonna put chocolate fudge our whole like
it from me from the corporate office
once a month all right you know how it
is [ __ ] deal
well I mean there's a difference and you
sorry I'm not mad at those kind of Jim
are you sign a confidentiality agreement
then whatever happens I need to take
pictures of you I'll do nothing we're
always cover them if you do take them
out you pull it John Gotti you gotta be
never make eleven million dollars he was
[ __ ] mark gasps - those wife oh really
whoa what castelo's wife was yeah dress
yes she another Mary Stallone right
right well I think there was somebody
else Gotti was datin and he couldn't be
seen with her in public so he just would
set her up at one of his friends so they
would go to Nick games and you would be
there but you'd sit next to leak no I'm
taking you home but they called beards
beats you know what a [ __ ] alley model
yeah I don't know much about it seems
like you do have a plan though no no I
don't have a plan because I dated a girl
who had a sugar daddy and when she told
me about it it crushed me and because I
didn't know that existed I didn't that's
how they Eve I was I was I'm hip on you
know I'm watching the show I was telling
Terry before you came that I don't give
a [ __ ] about Marcia's I don't give a
[ __ ] about politics I don't give a [ __ ]
about nothing I can follow by human
behavior and intelligent and why what
people judge is intelligence or people
don't judge intelligence
and I've always loved writers like
Hemmingway and all that type of [ __ ] but
I'm watching that show Jota Jota the guy
that was Pablo Escobar's hitman that
turned himself in and the first 40
episodes it was so unbelievable that I
had to really like investigate the guy
and watch another documentary and they
said at the end they said Pablo Escobar
was a genius when it came to part of
that stuff but his main source was this
young kid there's no anartha and they
just people who God puts on this planet
with that type of mind your ex is very
good at what he does at his business his
business God put him on this planet to
be a great manager the universe alien
my wife is good with accounts you were a
great writer this [ __ ] guy I'm
watching episode 20 and I think I'll
about it and these are all true stories
of what he was doing there was a new
warden in the prison that would do daily
canal to yourself go Trias I'll rip your
mattress and when your wives came in now
he had the police stick things up your
wife's [ __ ] to make sure they weren't
bringing drugs or money in so nobody
could smuggle drugs anymore so Lisa at I
wanted to kill halt the whole top pop by
right so pop I went into a selfie oh
[ __ ] you
look I'm gonna take care of your hitch
you can't get another year cocaine of
him I'm gonna bring it in guys like
you'll never do it how do you think
caught the ha'la'tha brought the coca he
hid it in the wardens car and the warden
would park in front of his house he
would have one of his friends go at 4:00
in the morning put a kilo underneath the
car at the panel and then they would
drive the car in and they pay a [ __ ]
cop to go take the kilo out there's
people that have different minds for
different things like they just really
versus natural you know
Harvey's mind you know these people's my
Cosby is mine maybe immaculate Cosby was
living with you know I always talk about
Jeffrey Dahmer think about going home
tonight Felicia eating a steak right you
know kissing your kids goodbye and then
knowing that Lisa ass under your bed
dead there for a week think of what mind
is what is that where they just don't
have any remorse yeah they can't feel
Psychopaths I don't think it's way
beyond the Psychopaths what listen one
time you know one family you know what
my friend told me about we were kids
will got girls morning falesha Oh
let's banish fly let's fly yeah okay so
my friend don't we met this man is fly
this is a cute little girl on my block
plane Felicia I'm gonna invite her over
for lemonade it was some Spanish for hi
and one you actually pass out Felicia
night can I go in your shirt so I
squeeze your titties
after a bother I feel remorseful and I
don't do it and I never do it again what
that you should be in trouble for the
first night you'll wake up and just say
what the [ __ ] you'll be okay your pants
won't be on backwards well imagine if
that happened today magic no I'm just
saying one time okay my mind is what
makes you do that how much power the
Kasbah had that he would actually bring
him to his [ __ ] trailer do you know
how many chicks said that he [ __ ]
raped him right in the trailer but they
came to the cellular show while I was on
a show like a comedy strip live comic
strip live these to do at the Laugh
Factory and the makeup artist told me
going if you're ever on a stage with
cause being you'd be careful like that
was caught it was out this is like years
and you what he was this this had been
like 91 92 maybe around there 3 I don't
know something like that yeah so it was
common knowledge but what do you do if
you know if you hear something and you
can't prove it and then you know cuz
then what do you do if you do say
something you know it's quite a Felicia
in your world
I'm not saying it's that that's the
right in your world to find what's going
on
what really offends you as a woman right
now like what what a guy have to do like
you know like would it be your ass just
I love you and try to be funny with him
trying to just see what what's really
going on I wanted to have you on today
not just look at your beautiful face but
just see the temperature because
sometimes I get confused I don't know
what a lot of words mean I'm not here
molesting people I'm not here doping
people or groping anybody but it's
getting so sensitive that I'm really
thinking of not even putting my arm
around a woman doing a picture this is
what gets on my nerves like when the
whole Louie thing came out there were
there was guy comics that were like
putting up all the articles and and and
we're like you know I saw Chloe [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that yeah and [ __ ] Louie I get
it but then like one of the guys the
next day had a picture of him in his
three friends and and they were like
we're going to go see the we got into
the screening of the Woody Allen movie
yeehaw and it's like that that's what is
sickening about it it's like everyone's
knee-jerk reaction is like yeah [ __ ] the
Go Go Bob of a bluff but then people are
still participating in the behavior if
not doing the actual behavior in not
understanding that you know what I mean
how ironic that is like you're saying Oh
Louise bad but then you're excited to go
to a Woody Allen movie who's been
accused of molesting his own daughter
you know so it you know like I just wish
people would take a stance and kind of
stick at it or like when this whole
thing first came out and you and I had
huge conversations about it and to be
able to talk to you so that you see a
different side of it me because of what
I'm saying and I think that's what the
great thing is now is all these women
are coming out I mean I'm no spring
chicken and I had a guy touch my [ __ ]
puss two years ago in a club another
comic that didn't have any money and
that's a drug you know what I mean but
and the fact that that happened to me
like someone who's not 21 and you know
and
worldly that a person has that much
privilege that they can do that it's not
okay
and and to know that like with my
ex-husband you know it's such a
complicated thing to talk about but that
when that's touched my ex-husband's life
in business that he's experiencing you
know you know going through that as
someone's protector manager whatever and
to know at the same time his ex-wife is
is also being assaulted that's how much
sex abuse and sexual harassment and
[ __ ] is going on right now it's like
you know every girl you know has five
different stories you know like it's
we're all connected by it and we have to
figure out what the right thing to do
about it is and it's good that we're
having this conversation finally because
what we and it's good that media and
comedians kind of kicked it off in a way
it's terrible but at least we're trying
to take care of it
you know they fire Matt Lauer Louie lost
shows at least there is a repercussion
yet the fact that Trump is in the White
House and has been accused by even more
women is ridiculous it's ridiculous like
everyone's got to be on the same page or
shut the [ __ ] up you know and it's not
fair at all and and it's your sisters
and I hate to be this person I'm just
gonna stop myself because you know the
whole [ __ ] spiel you know does this
mean you won't take pictures of my
nutsack ever I'll take it let me get out
can I and can I have the [ __ ]
right sorry to be that person sorry what
it was today at the same time I'm trying
to teach my son's not to be a misogynist
and giving them condoms to have sex and
saying protect women and be respectful
and don't share pictures of a girl sends
you a picture and I'm trying to do that
to my son you know what I mean like like
we have to figure it out because what
about for your daughter or
Lee has kids and you know I mean like we
got to figure it out anyway
my apologies well thank you thank you
for yours this is why why did you wanna
tell you especially after the Matt Lauer
thing how weird cuz he shocked that that
was shocked me he seems like the
sweetest guy in the world you feel
cheated as an American whether it was
Louie it caused me now something that
you really liked admired growing up and
they kind of let you down a minute you
know Matt Lauer my life still goes on I
still gotta go pay for groceries at
rouse and we still be paying a mortgage
but it just takes away a little bit
familiar
solutely even my youngest because we
would always watch as we eat breakfast a
TV in the kitchen and watch NBC the
Today Show and today he woke up as a
young teenage man you know and looks on
his phone while he's in bed he's like
[ __ ] Matt Lauer - and and feeling like
oh that way you know that was someone I
looked up to was somebody drove to tell
you I got a brilliant book from Bob Lowe
Angus who his family on a Chicago big
White Sox fan I love him to death
I read a [ __ ] disturbing chapter that
I had heard about before but it was the
Jimmy Page whatever - when he told was a
13 year old girl yeah you know I mean he
[ __ ] that girl for years Jimmy Page's
a grown man she was 13 and why doesn't
anybody talk about that what do you
wanna know is a 1972 her boobs on oh I
took it a court the attorney will say
that's the first thing excuse me before
what drugs did you consume that night
there was a Led Zeppelin show was it not
where you sobered the time yeah I was a
member a ain't no you weren't you did
acid you do not remember she was 18 shut
the [ __ ] up
what's his name David is niece or nephew
the piano player then he dated a 16 year
old girl Billy Joel no you know the
other guy the guy that's really fast on
a piano in the 60s the 50s
Oh Jerry Jerry Lee Lewis yes he yeah
yeah he's really more because oh no he
dated this cousin yeah
way younger 16 this [ __ ] like that I
thank you and don't forget Felicia's
Michael's one-woman show premieres
January 26 and 27 and I'm also gonna be
at the Denver improv on Valentine's Day
are you that's a good show man this is a
good [ __ ] - he got me in the business
let me talk to you people about two
things and we'll call it a [ __ ]
afternoon all right number one
everybody's looking for a hustle when
you drive for the right ride-sharing app
every trip can feel like a walk in the
park with lyft you can pick your own
hours and drive when you want lift makes
driving the best gig in the world so the
more you drive the more money you make
that's a type of action you get cliff
know that that drive is what keeps them
moving so they do everything they can
possible to make sure their drivers are
happy on every trip it's a simple
formula happy drivers means happy
passengers done
maybe that's why nine out of ten lift
rides get a perfect five-star rating now
the holidays are here guys he's gonna
hundreds of dollars a week plus tips you
want to earn more you drive law it's
never been that easy to give yourself a
raise now lift was the first ride share
platform with tipping built right into
the app because getting tip shouldn't
depend on the passenger having a crumple
doing their pocket you keep all the
percent of the tips and they add up fast
drivers have been paid over two hundred
mill since the feature was first
introduced and with Express Bank you get
paid instantly you don't got to wait
three four weeks to get your money lyft
is even taking the guesswork out of
pickups the new hand device uses color
coding to help passengers find their
drivers so do me a favor
join the ride-sharing app would join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to lift
calm slash Joey today not tomorrow not
Friday today right now and you get a
$500 new bonus lieu driver bonus that's
right
plus the money you make driving
that's live.com slash Joey again
live.com slash Joey limited time only
and terms applies [ __ ] every year
millions of people receive the least
like gift of all time [ __ ] along the way
unless they're [ __ ] sexy a little
thong and [ __ ]
you know I'm sayin but we still give it
to our family and I love ones who just
don't want it maybe it's because it's
not the underwear it's a problem it's
the kind of [ __ ] underwear let me
tell you about me undies that's the only
underwear that makes an amazing gift
there's soft flexible flexible waistband
three times ruffling cotton and let me
tell you some my camouflage ones are
four years old and I still got it
that's all I wear is me on this I wear
them to jujitsu I wear them to the gym
they keep your nuts comfortable they
keep the sweat out there they got the
mold door which keeps the moisture out
of your nutsack and that's what you want
to ask well when you're young man and
you're dating nobody wants to pick a
woman up with sweaty stinky nutsack
so me undies is the undies for you me
undies made underwear the perfect gift
that everyone's gonna love you for and
it's a goddamn holiday miracle this year
don't give underwear and give me on this
what I'm gonna do is this it's a holiday
season I'm gonna get you 20% off the
best underwear and socks you'll ever
wear I'm gonna get your free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me on these calms where's Joey
again that's me undies dot-coms where's
Joey the best underwear you ever put on
they're not even underwear they're
[ __ ] like space suits you follow me
for your nutsack don't forget you're
gonna join jujitsu this year and try to
get make better yourself if you're a fat
[ __ ] Fuji sports calm 15% off code
Church start off with the purple ghee or
the lightweight I'll go right for the
separate oh and knock yourself out
and don't forget the holidays are coming
December's gonna be dead leaves and I
have to strip that month to make extra
money so instead if you're gonna buy
something on Amazon
click on our battle where's the banner
instead of Joey Diaz Nanette's right
there go to Joey Diaz dotnet and the
banners right there and Lee gets a piece
of the [ __ ] action all right I want
to thank Felicia Michaels for coming
again most importantly I want to thank
all you [ __ ] for being soldiers
I'll see you Sunday night in the noble
theater or some Monday night in San
Diego I love you guys have a great
weekend stay black